For those of you who are
curious, we will go through an
argument that establishes that
the set of real numbers is an
uncountable set.
It's a famous argument
known as Cantor's
diagonalization argument.
Actually, instead of looking
at the set of all real
numbers, we will first look at
the set of all numbers, x,
that belong to the open
unit interval--
so numbers between 0 and 1--
and such that their decimal
expansion involves
only threes and fours.
Now, the choice of three and
four is somewhat arbitrary.
It doesn't matter.
What really matters is
that we do not have
long strings of nines.
So suppose that this
set was countable.
If the set was countable, then
that set could be written as
equal to a set of this form,
x1, x2, x3 and so on, where
each one of these is a real
number inside that set.
Now, suppose that this
is the case.
Let us take those numbers
and write them
down in decimal notation.
For example, one number
could be this one, and
it continues forever.
Since we're talking about real
numbers, their decimal
expansion will go on forever.
Suppose that the second number
is of this kind, and it has
its own decimal expansion.
Suppose that the third number
is, again, with some decimal
expansion and so on.
So we have assumed that our
set is countable and
therefore, the set is equal
to that sequence.
So this sequence exhausts all
the numbers in that set.
Can it do that?
Let's construct a new number
in the following fashion.
The new number looks
at this digit and
does something different.
Looks at this digit, the second
digit of the second
number, and does something
different.
Looks at the third digit of
the third number and does
something different.
And we continue this way.
This number that we have
constructed here is different
from the first number.
They differ in the
first digit.
It's different from
the second number.
They differ in the
second digit.
It's different from the third
number because it's different
in the third digit and so on.
So this is a number, and this
number is different
from xi for all i.
So we have an element of this
set which does not belong to
this sequence.
Therefore, it cannot be true
that this set is equal to the
set formed by that sequence.
And so this is a contradiction
to the initial assumption that
this set could be written
in this form, and this
contradiction establishes that
since this is not possible,
that the set that we have here
is an uncountable set.
Now, this set is a subset of
the set of real numbers.
Since this one is uncountable,
it is not hard to show that
the set of real numbers, which
is a bigger set, will also be
uncountable.
And so this is this particular
famous argument.
We will not need it or make any
arguments of this type in
this class, but it's so
beautiful that it's worth for
everyone to see it once
in their lifetime.